it's a common misconception that price
levels are dictated purely by the
quantity of money out there and to see
why this isn't the case let's imagine an
island that has two players in it so it
has a farmer who obviously will produce
food and it also has a let's call them a
landlord landlord / builder who will
either rent out buildings or can build
you more buildings or build themselves
more buildings to rent rent out and
we're living in a reality where all you
need is food and shelter and let's
imagine one reality where they've this
this island or whatever this country
whatever you want to call it they
haven't discovered a lot of currency so
they only have a little bit of gold
so maybe the farmer only has a couple of
gold coins to start off with and the
landlord / Builder also only has a
couple of gold coins to start off with
they're very they're very currency poor
only a little bit of gold but they're
very optimistic the farmer says hey you
know what things are looking good
landlord I want to rent I want to rent a
nice building from you for my family and
for you to build more buildings so here
take both of these coins and get and
build me it or rent me out something
nice and he gets both coins over here
and then the landlord below says wow you
know things are good the farmer seems
pretty optimistic farmer I want you to
buy me I want you to grow me a ton of
really good food because things are good
so here take four coins take four coins
for me and and and really grow me grow
me a ton of really nice food that I you
know stuff that that takes a lot of
that's really hard to grow so grow to
grow a ton of food for me so he gets
those four coins now he gets the four
coins these are now gone the farmer
doesn't have those anymore
now the farmers feeling really great
really optimistic and said and of course
these are now gone now the landlord has
given them to the farmer the farmers
feeling really optimistic says landlord
you know what I'm feeling even better
than I did before why don't you build me
even a few more buildings right you know
I want to expand my house even more but
now the lander is like man you know you
already given me a lot of money and I
already have a lot of work to do you got
to pay me more if you want me to work
overtime because that's going to take
time away
for my family and all the rest and the
farmer says sure last time I paid you to
two gold coins for some buildings I'll
now pay three gold coins for the same
number of buildings and so he gives he
gives three gold coins for what and all
he's going to get in return is what he
used to get for two gold coins so if you
think about it the price has gone up for
whatever service or product the land the
Builder is providing and then he gives
those three gold coins to the landlord
and the Builder and then the Builder
says well you know things are really
good I'm getting a lot of business phone
farmer I can get even more food from the
farmer and he goes to the farmer says
hey give me what you just gave me that
last time for two gold coins but the
farmer says no you know what I'm really
busy now I I'm almost tapped out if you
want me to work overtime or expand my
facilities you got to give me three gold
coins for what I gave before and besides
that the cost of buying houses has just
gone up to three gold coins so you had
to give me three gold coins now and so
the Builder says oh sure I'll give you
three gold coins so the one thing I want
you to notice in this video is we only
had two we only started off with two
gold coins for each of these players but
because they were really confident
because they kept spending it with each
other because there were a lot of
transactions there was a high velocity
of the actual money that you actually
had an increase in prices